an interview a few days ago that Ron
DeSantis did with CB and that's
Christian broadcast network and one of
the questions came up if Trump gets
indicted what would you do as president
what about there's been talk about if
for some reason he was convicted a
potential pardon what a president
DeSantis potentially so I said when I
before that even happened that we have
an uneven justice system we've seen it
weaponized I'm going to end the
weaponization and part of ending the
weaponization is yes we're going to
clean house at FBI Justice can do a lot
but part of it is using your Article 2
powers to redress wrongs including
potentially Pardons and so we we said
this is even before this happened with
Trump you know we'll have people who've
been wronged before we come into office
apply we're going to look if there was a
different standard we're going to be
very inclined to grant clemency and
those body language Clarity competency
there's a real irony also with Trump
right now which is that DeSantis is
probably your best chance possibly your
best chance to not end up in jail he's
telling you he's telling you you'll get
the pardon if he's President right if
Biden's president you ain't getting the
pardon